أريد أن أعطي لخردة الحياة مرة أخرى ، أجلب
لشخص جديد عيني مزيجًا من المفاهيم الخيالية ،
اسمي كوري أكولا وأنا فنان
وأشهر أنني
صنعت منحوتات روبرت المتحركة التي عثروا عليها في
صنع الروبوتات التي كانت تصنع المنحوتات
من الخردة المعدنية التي عثرت عليها ثم
بدأت في تحريك تلك الأجزاء المتحركة باستخدام
مكابس ضغط الهواء التي بدأت
برأس يحرك الفك وقبل أن أعرف ذلك
كان لدي روبوت وجدت نفسي إلى حد كبير في
كل مكان أفتح فيه عيني  من
المحتمل أن يكون الوقت رائعًا ، أعني
[موسيقى]
هناك كل نوع من الأشكال التي يمكنك
تخيلها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عندما أنشأت ، أتذكر أنني بدأت
بشكل واضح مع الموسيقى التي تجعل أجزاء من
الأصابع تسد الزبون ثم قمت
ببناء الجزرة من  وراء ذلك ،
الشيء المميز حول أختي
الآلية التي تقوم فعليًا بتشغيل الموسيقى بنفسها ،
يعزف الروبوت الخاص بي على الغيتار الجهير ومجموعة
الطبل ويعزفون على الناي
[تصفيق]
لديهم تقارب مع موسيقى البانك روك
، الفرقة بأكملها تُدعى إلى حب واحد
الورقة الخلفية التي
أداها الروبوت الخاص بي في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
الأحداث التقنية ، المهرجانات ،
المحاضرات الجامعية أو محادثات TED
عندما يقوم الناس بتجربة الروبوتات ،
تقلى قليلاً لفترة من الوقت ، هذه لحظة أمل ،
ما يحدث هنا ومن ثم فمن السهل جدًا
أن تكون طفولية ومبهجة.
أرغب في استخدام أداة تجميع الخردة لأن
هناك الكثير من الأماكن التي لا يمكن للعالم
تدميرها ، ولا يمكنك تحسينها إلا أن
عملي هو لعبة حظ مستمرة
وهذا ما أحبه حقًا
[موسيقى]